the bottom line here is the 737 Max is
safe and flight has crashed shortly
safety questions this morning because
this is the second crash in just five
months
safety is at the core of who we are at
Boeing
when the Boeing 737 and Max 8 first
entered service in May of 2017. it was
touted as it being the new standard for
narrow body Aviation and while this was
a bold claim no one really contested it
except maybe Airbus after all 737s had
been reliably flying since 1967. so it's
not too surprising that the newest
version of the 737 would take the crown
of being the most reliable and the most
efficient for the longest time it seemed
like this was indeed the case leading
Airlines like Southwest were receiving
dozens of 737 Maxes and they were being
used almost immediately
within a year of launch 130 planes had
been delivered to 28 different airlines
and at Max's across the world had flown
42 000 flights transporting 6.5 million
people at this point I think it was safe
to say that the 737 Max was proving to
be just another routine upgrade for
Boeing but all of this would change on
October 29 2018 at 6 20 am Lion Air
Flight 610 took off from Jakarta
Indonesia and almost immediately the
pilot started noticing some weird things
the plane was telling them that the
aircraft was in danger of stalling and
it appeared that the flight controls
were all screwed up the speed and
altitude readings were way off and it
felt like the nose of the aircraft was
being pushed down the pilots promptly
contacted air traffic controller and
requested permission to return to
Jakarta but it was already too late just
13 minutes after takeoff air traffic
control would lose contact with the
Flight 610 they would go ahead and
inform the national Search and Rescue
Agency who deployed three ships and a
helicopter around the area in which
contact was lost and what they found was
devastating Flight 610 had crashed into
the Java sea in Europe and oil platform
killing all 189 people on board workers
on the nearby oil platform said that the
plane was essentially an uncontrollably
nose diving before crashing while this
was no doubt an international tragedy
most people didn't look into it much
more than just that after all a Lion Air
had a history of safety concerns and
poor Management in fact they were even
banned from flying in European airspace
up until 2016. so much of the world just
wrote it off as an isolated incident and
issued a warning but the 737 Max
remained in service Flash Forward five
months and it seemed like things were
going fine 737 Max's had been routinely
flying for nearly two years now making
it more and more likely that a Flight
610 it truly was just a one-off tragedy
but this would change on March 10 2019
at 8 38 am Ethiopian Airlines flight 302
took off from Addis Ababa Ethiopia just
one minute into the flight the pilot
started reporting flight control issues
and that the aircraft was pitching
downward and just five minutes after
that the planet nose dived into the
ground at 700 miles per hour once again
killing everyone on board this crash was
taken out much more seriously it was
extraordinarily unlikely that the same
issue took place twice within a matter
of months just by chance within the next
72 hours 737 Maxes were grounded around
the world as it was clear who was at
fault since then much of Boeing's
leadership has been ousted Boeing has
paid it billions of dollars in fines and
settlements and public sentiment has
very much turned against the Boeing but
likely the most haunting evidence that
has come out since then it is a 117 page
reported detailing it internal
Communications at Boeing regarding the
737 Max one Boeing Employee said quote
this is a joke this airplane is
ridiculous and that this was a way back
in 2016 years before either incident
another employee wrote I honestly don't
trust many people at Boeing clearly
engineers at Boeing knew that the 737
Max wasn't a fit to fly yet the aircraft
managed to pass all of its inspections
with flying colors and hundreds of
millions of people continued to find
Boeing aircraft including many world
leaders but if even Boeing Engineers
don't trust Boeing why should we
foreign
if you look at the situation at face
value you'll probably think that the 737
Max 8 was just a one-off incident after
all Boeing has been manufacturing planes
for over a hundred years and they rarely
have such issues right well this is true
it is rare that Boeing has issues but
the key thing to note is why they even
have issues in the first place Boeing
has produced tens of thousands of
aircraft over the decades so it's only
natural that they have a few hiccups
here and there regardless of how careful
they are if this was the fate of the 737
Max 8 it would actually be somewhat
understandable but the 737 Max 8 wasn't
caused by an honest oversight or bad
luck it was caused by Deep rooted
negligence and ignorance that's been
rampant within the company for decades
and the 737 Max 8 was by no means the
first example of this one of the first
examples of their negligence dates back
to the late 1980s with the car door
incident the story starts off on March
10 1987 with a Pan Am flight from London
to New York the journey started off
perfectly fine and would go smoothly up
until the plane reached an altitude of
20 000 feet at which point the crew
noticed that the cabin was
depressurizing so the pilots would
decrease the altitude to 15 000 feet at
which point the pressurization problems
disappeared thinking that the first
occurrence was just a fluke the pilots
would increase the altitude to 20 000
feet once again and I Clockwork the
problems would reappear fortunately the
pilots did not try to push the
boundaries and it just turned around and
returned to London once the plane was on
the ground the aircraft was examined
which revealed that all of the cargo
door locking arms had either been
damaged or completely sheared off Boeing
would initially blame this incident on a
ground crew mishandling the cargo door
but a few years later it would become
clear who was truly at fault on February
24 1989 United Airlines flight 811 and
would take off from Los Angeles heading
towards Sydney the flight had two
intermittent stops on the way though at
Honolulu Hawaii and Auckland New Zealand
the first leg of the flight was
completed flawlessly with no concerns or
issues the second leg started off fine
too up until the flight crossed 20 000
feet at which point everyone on board
heard a loud thump before anyone could
even react though the cargo door swung
open with such force that it ripped open
the entire aircraft at 22 000 feet in
the air nine passengers would be
catapulted out of the aircraft and would
it all die everyone else on board
assumed that an explosion had gone off
and that they were under attack
miraculously the pilots were able to
turn around the aircraft and return to
Honolulu and it once the plane was on
the ground the flight crew expeditiously
unloaded everyone within just 45 seconds
terrified that another explosion would
go off but after extensive research that
lasted years it was determined that the
cause of the incident was not an
explosion but rather their 40
Engineering in the cargo door that could
have been fixed if Boeing took the first
incident more seriously this in itself
is pretty troubling but the story gets
even worse and 26 years later in 2015 an
FAA investigator would complete a
routine checkup on Boeing's factories
and suppliers when he ran into a
mechanic working on a Triple 7 cargo
door when questioned about his work the
mechanic would tell the inspector that
he does not use the inspection tools
required it and it enters false
inspection data on a work order
furthermore he admitted to falsely
entering the data for approximately
seven to eight years and it's not that
the mechanic did not want to perform
their inspections but rather that the
quotas from Boeing were so high that he
didn't have the time or resources to do
so and if this mechanic alone had been
doing this for seven to eight years
imagine how many decades this issue may
have been ongoing at the Boeing this may
have been the reason for the United
Airlines disaster in 1989 but the fine
for all this was a me easily 12 million
dollars
the cargo door incident and the 737 Max
incident are just two of many boring
incidents in recent history 787
Dreamliners have had issues with leaking
fuel they've also had issues with
batteries catching on fire the FAA has
also found inadequate inspections
techniques on multiple occasions but how
did Boeing get so bad they obviously
weren't always bad at one point in
history they were the leaders in the
aviation industry pushing forward
Innovation and bringing out aircraft
like the 747. how did they go from that
to this well usually with these sorts of
things there's never a singular reason
but one large Catalyst that many
Aviation experts point to it is the
McDonald Douglas acquisition in 1997.
before this acquisition Boeing was
largely filled with engineers in fact
people often described a bowling as an
Association of Engineers as opposed to
an actual company obviously Boeing
themselves were slowly shifting away
from this by the late 1990s but MD
aggressively accelerated this transition
you see it MD was the exact opposite of
Boeing they had a reputation of cutting
corners and maximizing profits over
everything else considering this I don't
know why Boeing decided to even acquire
them but they did and almost immediately
you could see the effect if you're a fan
of the aviation industry you'd know that
a substantial amount of Boeing
manufacturing and Engineering takes
place in Seattle Washington so you would
assume that their headquarters were also
in Seattle but this is not the case
after the MD acquisition the HQ was
moved from Seattle to Chicago and now
it's in Virginia the official reasoning
for this was that the Boeing wanted a
more central location for their HQ but
in reality it seems that MD was able to
convince Boeing to separate their
engineers and Leadership this would make
it easier for leadership to implement a
questionable cost-cutting measures while
minimizing backlash from engineers and
that's exactly what they did over the
next couple of years Boeing would
aggressively Outsource airplane
construction integrating more than 50
Partners pretty soon they got to a point
where the majority of parts weren't even
produced by Boeing Boeing factory is
turned into assembly plants where
pre-made parts were just bolted together
in fact less than 40 percent of the 787
is actually built by Boeing and this is
extremely dangerous given their industry
when Apple's contractors grew up and
their iPhones end up bending it it's not
a big deal but when a Boeing's
contractors grew up and the flaps don't
work or the car core door doesn't close
it's deadly literally nonetheless Boeing
would double down on this pad and in
2005 they would hire their first CEO
without the aircraft engineering
experience Jim McNerney to this day
insiders joked that McDonald Douglas
bought bowling with Boeing's money I
think you can guess why this is such a
popular joke
foreign
with such unsettling evidence coming out
against the bullying you would think
that they would make sweeping changes
but as we just discussed this is not the
first time that such evidence has come
out against the Boeing and if they
didn't change in the past it's not a
very compelling case that they'll change
now and the truth is that they have no
reason to change it because they won't
face any consequences sure they had to
pay a hefty fine and sit through a bunch
of media backlash but at the end of the
day they still have a duopoly with
Airbus and no one is challenging that
it's not like people are going to stop
going on business trips or Vacations or
any of that and if we're being honest
how many people even know what aircraft
they're flying on they just booked the
cheapest flight or the most convenient
flight they might have a preference for
the airline but they almost never have a
preference for the aircraft itself
unless their Aviation nerds so it's not
like Boeing's reputation is going to
hurt their top line over the long term
and that's just the Ava side of things
if we look at the space and defense side
of things they have so many government
contracts worth tens of billions that
that's not even funny there is some hope
though while it doesn't look like the
government or the public will hold a
Boeing accountable it looks like their
own questionable practices will it turns
out that Outsourcing everything to
people who don't know what they're doing
it doesn't actually work out over the
long term I mean who would have thought
excessive Outsourcing has resulted in it
in several production flaws with the 787
which has severely limited production
and deliveries this has resulted in
Boeing losing billions of dollars at
every quarter in fact they haven't had a
single profitable 12-month period since
the 737 Max Fiasco and you can't blame
this on Covert either given that Airbus
is more profitable than ever so it looks
like Boeing is finally getting a taste
of their own medicine but that's just
what I think do you trust Boeing comment
that down below also drop a like if
you're glad that Boeing is finally
feeling some pain and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community to
suggest future video ideas and to
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]